and by using the formula, we can alternatively write that state like you see right here.
This formula works for all choices of b, so by linearity, it works
for an arbitrary state SI
in place of cat b.
And in particular, if we want to, we can choose SI to be the minus state.
And now here's the key to why the phase x kickback
phenomenon happens.
It's because the x operation
applied to the minus state gives us negative 1 times the minus state.
In mathematical terms, we say that the minus
state is an eigenvector of the x operation, with eigen value equal to negative 1.
Eigenvectors and eigen values
are critically important in linear algebra as well
as in quantum information, and we'll have a lot
more to say about them
as the series continues.
But for now, all we need
is this simple formula.
And using it, we can
simplify our state vector.
And that right there is essentially the phase
kickback phenomenon written as a formula.
It works because the minus
state is an eigenvector of the NOT operation having
eigen value negative one.
We will generalize this in a
pretty major way in Lesson 7, when we turn to the phase
estimation procedure, which is what drives
Shor's factoring algorithm.
We can see this formula in action in the analysis of Deutsch's
algorithm as follows.
Prior to the query gate, our state is the tensor product of the minus and plus states.
We then apply the query gate, and expanding out the plus
state gives us this state.
We now apply the phase kickback formula to get this expression, and then the analysis
carries on as before.
It's the same as before, but here we're just placing
a focus on the phase kickback so that we can recognize it
and we can also be ready for
it when it comes up again.
Next we'll turn to the
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, which is an extension
of Deutsch's algorithm that actually solves a couple
of different query problems.
The advantage that
Deutsch's algorithm provides over classical algorithms
is pretty modest, one query versus two.
The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm increases that advantage somewhat, and I'll explain what I mean
by that when we get there.
The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm can be viewed as a natural and direct way of extending Deutsch's algorithm
from functions from one bit to one bit to functions from n bits to one bit, or another words, functions of this form.
As a quantum circuit, the Deutsch-Jozsa
algorithm looks like this, and I'm going to refer to this
as the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
just to draw a minor
distinction between this circuit and the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm itself because there's also a
classical post-processing step.
The idea is that if we run
this circuit and then measure, we'll obtain some n bits string y
that tells us something
about the function f.
At this point, by the way, I haven't actually said
what the query problem is that we might hope to
solve with this circuit, that's coming up very soon.
But the point is that
by running this circuit, we'll gain some information about f that can potentially help
us to solve query problems
where f is the input. And like I said a moment ago, we can actually use this circuit
to solve a couple of
different query problems.
First, let's take a look
at the query problem known as the Deutsch-Jozsa problem, which is the problem that
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
was originally intended to solve.
The Deutsch-Jozsa problem is a generalization of Deutsch's problem, where the goal is to determine whether a given function
is constant or balanced.
Notice that this isn't the natural way to generalize the parity problem
to functions of this form.
Here we're not computing the parity, the task is to output 0 if
the function f is constant
and 1 if the function f is balanced.
The first thing to notice about
this problem is that when n, the number of input bits to
the function f, is at least 2,
there are choices for the function that are neither constant nor balanced.
For example, here's a
function from 2 bits to 1 bit that's neither constant nor balanced.
It's not constant because both binary values
appear among the outputs, and it's not balanced
because the two output values
appear with different frequencies. 0 appears three times
and 1 appears just once.
In order to be balanced,
the outputs 0 and 1 have to occur exactly
the same number of times.
The fact that there are functions that are neither constant nor balanced when n is at least 2 is okay though, we're just gonna consider
functions like that
as "don't care" inputs. So in other words, this
is a promise problem.
And here's a precise
statement of the problem.